[Music]
CNN MSNBC in the New York Times are
working together tonight to push a new
story but the Trump administration at
the top of the hour MSNBC put on Maggie
Haberman scene and put on Michael
Schmidt those two are both times
reporters and they co-authored a piece
in that newspaper saying the Donald
Trump attempted to fire Robert Muller in
December Muller still there of course
the Moller investigation you'll remember
was officially created to uncover
Russian hacking into the American
democracy because they act our democracy
but that's not what it is anymore it is
now an all-purpose probe into the
president his personal and financial
life it's designed to make us feel safer
I hope you feel safer yesterday FBI
agents raided the office of Michael Koh
and that's the president's personal
lawyer apparently looking for evidence
about payments to stormy Daniels the
porn star who is not from Russia and who
did not hack our election in any case
over at MSNBC Steve Schmidt noted that
the many where the Constitution would be
thrilled by this they always hated the
Bill of Rights those guys if you listen
closely tonight you you can hear the
faint applause from heaven of this
country's founding fathers who
bequeathed to us a nation where the rule
of law is supreme we are a nation of
laws yeah the founders wanted to know
did the money go to stormy Daniels what
happened to stormy Daniels Johnathan
Shirley's professor at George Washington
University School of Law and he joins us
tonight so I think professor you were
one of the trustworthy people in this
conversation I don't even know what your
politics are I don't think we even agree
politically whatever I trust your legal
views what do you make of this raid on
the president's lawyers offices well
part of this is of Cohen's making in the
sense that Cohen tends to blur his
relationships between being a lawyer a
fixer and that's a business partner
that's that's dangerous under any
circumstance but it's particularly
dangerous if you're going to invoke the
attorney-client privilege because first
you have to prove that you're acting
like an attorney and he may have trouble
with that when you look at the stormy
Daniels Agreement it's still not clear
what role he's playing there whether he
is this company he created whether he is
Trump's lawyer
that's going to come back to haunt him
and haunt the president when they say
some of this stuff should remain
confidential but I think the president
is right and since that whenever you
have a raid on an attorney's office it
should raise very troubling concerns for
everyone I mean this is a serious
problem when someone can't rely on their
attorneys so is the core potential
violation here that the payments to
stormy Daniels miss Daniels will call
her were some form of campaign finance
violations well actually that is
strengthening with some of the
statements made publicly when the
president said I didn't know anything
about this payment it sounds a lot like
what's called an in-kind campaign
contribution and that's what John
Edwards was charged with and prosecuted
for he ultimately was not convicted of
that but yes they could make a case like
that but supposedly they warrant covers
everything from stormy Daniels to taxi
medallions and there's a lot in between
is there any indication that stormy
Daniels was working with Russian agents
to influence the outcome of the election
that she was herself part of the hacking
of our democracy well I'm not familiar
with all four movies but no I I'm not
familiar with okay so I guess we can say
that the nature of the investigation has
changed profoundly oh absolutely no
there's no question that this is far off
the mark
so was man afford what he actually sort
of fascinating about this is that rod
Rosen see didn't have much of a problem
when Muller came to him and said I want
to expand mana for its investigation to
include stuff to the Kurd years before
we're not connected to the campaign some
of this stuff is actually closer and yet
Rosa Dean said I want the Southern
District to do this could Rosen Cena
said no that's not the original charter
of this that's not the point of this
investigation she could have but it gets
a little bit tough if Muller came to him
and said look we actually have evidence
of crime that we have uncovered it's
it's hard not to give that to a
prosecutor to look at but we don't know
what was was shown to rod Rosenstein and
that's part of the process you would
have to I think what you're saying is
you'd have to be either dumb or an
active drug user to allow an independent
counsel investigation to start well I
think that look this is one of those
things where it's
the road to you know unleash the dogs of
war it's harder to get them back and
yeah and a special counsel is a torpedo
in the water to use another metaphor and
he's still there and what's interesting
about this move is that they haven't
just expanded the the investigation
they've expanded the prosecutors so now
even if the president moved against
Rosenstein move against Muller it
wouldn't necessarily stop with the
Southern District is ya shoes thank you
for that Professor Jonathan Turley
appreciate it